this Sunday the south terminal at
London's Gatwick Airport will reopen to
the public after nearly two years closed
and I figured that reopening would just
be a case of the team here turning the
lights back on dusting off some
equipment and getting back to business
but from talking to the folks who are
getting everything ready it turns out
that mothballing an entire Airport
terminal for 18 months and then
reopening it again is much more
difficult than you might think in March
2020 when the pandemic struck we
obviously realized there was going to be
a significant downturn in traffic so we
took the decision to close one of our
terminals Gatwick Airport would
generally see upwards of 900 movements
off of our runway on a busy summer day
during the height of the pandemic we
were down to two or three flights a day
with certainly less than 500 passengers
on certain days I think it's fair to say
in March 2020 we all thought it'd be
over in two weeks time if the terminal
had been shut down for just a week or
maybe a month then yes things would
probably have just kept ticking over but
there's some point at which upkeep is
required in the same way that you're not
meant to leave a car sitting unused for
more than a couple of weeks the
mechanical Parts in things like the
baggage belts and Jet Bridges need to be
run tested and maintained regularly or
they might not start up ever again
closing the terminal does reduce costs
yes but it doesn't make them zero
there's a number of core Services we've
had to keep running we had to do regular
maintenance and safety checks on all of
our passenger boarding Bridges and
Airfield equipment Water Systems
Lighting systems power fire Life Safety
Systems everything that's there to look
after the people and keep everyone safe
but things like you know Heating and
Lighting in various areas and power for
escalators and lifts they were all shut
down mainly to save money during the
crisis you had to make Cuts wherever
possible we've been taking the
opportunity to use the space for filming
film companies and coming in and doing
various shows around the airport some of
which I think will be airing in the next
few weeks a large number of our
Workforce have been furloughed and since
the first of October we've had everyone
back in to get the airport back up and
running now as passenger numbers start
to grow you know we are actively
recruiting and we need to increase our
Workforce by a significant number we're
reopening 85 percent of it straight away
we've got a phase plan for our Airlines
moving back over from North Terminal
over three days but all the
infrastructure will come online more or
less from day one in terms of a
challenge yeah it's the biggest one I've
done at Gatwick airport it's been open
for 60 odd years that's now been closed
for the best part of two years you know
buildings don't react too well to that
sort of thing the scale of what we're
doing here is we've often likened it to
opening a smaller airport completely
from scratch it is a huge task that
we're undertaking I'm feeling really
confident actually I think you know
we're in a really good place to do it
the first flight from the south terminal
is scheduled to leave on Sunday in the
early hours of the morning so it'll
probably be about 3 A.M when the first
passengers go through the doors and they
probably won't know or care that the
terminals only just opened again they'll
just want to get to their destination if
everything goes to plan they probably
won't even know that the terminal was
ever closed
[Music]
[Applause]